green is good
green is right
green works
and
that that is that is the way ahead for
the whole planet because uh this cop 26
must be the moment when government joins
hands with the private sector together
with the with the mdbs with the the imf
the world bank we should be setting the
parameters the strike prices
uh the contract for difference for this
green technology we we should be using
this moment collectively as government
to leverage in the trillions of the
market creating the country platforms
that will not only tackle climate change
but deliver green jobs and green growth
around the world and uh here in the uk
that technological revolution is being
turbocharged by the second
of the three big changes that are that
is happening uh that are happening in
our country we're using our new freedoms
outside the eu to do things differently
and to regulate we hope better not just
when it comes to vaccines but in so many
areas of the 21st century economy where
the uk has a lead financial services
cyber ai quantum computing gene editing
data data
data
tech of all kinds fintech medtech ed
tech nanotech
green tech
starting to sound like 15th century
mexico uh we we have we have we lead the
world in tech we have um more than more
than there are any let me tell you there
are there are only three countries in
the world that have more than 100
unicorns you know what i mean by unicorn
it's uh it's a
a tech startup worth more than more than
a million a billion dollars and they are
they are the us uh china and the united
kingdom and the thing about our we've
got about 106 now i think and uh i'm
nearest european rival i won't mention
it by name uh i have i think about 24.
but nevermind uh
these the but the point about these
unicorns they are increasingly dispersed
around the uk
and there are tech unicorns in in
manchester in solihull and that brings
me to the third great transformation
that is that is happening now in our in
our country the overarching moral
political economic objective of this
government
and we believe i believe that talent and
genius and flair and imagination and
enthusiasm are distributed evenly
throughout the human race and throughout
the uk
but opportunity
is not
and for too long we've had in the uk a
grotesquely lopsided economy
so we are uniting and leveling up with a
colossal 640 billion pound program of
investment in infrastructure and
education and skills and in technology
we're investing in northern powerhouse
rail
and other massive projects connecting
the great urban centers of the north so
that there's the same ease of community
commuting the same agglomeration effects
that we've long seen in the south we're
putting gigabit broadband everywhere uh
it was seven percent uh when i first
became uh prime minister it's now rising
65 all propelled by rishi's wonderful
super deduction for capital investment
and we're investing in the skills skills
skills of the british people finally
tackling the productivity puzzle
okay that we have some of the most
productive companies anywhere in the
world but also this great long tail a
relative lack of productivity moving
from a low-wage low-skill economy to a
high-wage high-skill economy controlling
immigration but with a commitment to
global
talent and making sure that we are open
to people who want to come and make
their lives here and contribute to our
country and that is the plan
the green industrial revolution turbo
charged by new brexit freedoms with an
agenda to unite and level up across the
country we have all sorts of familiar
advantages or ones that you will have
heard
me say before possibly some of you
veterans
of my speeches jerry
the time zone we have the right time
zone we have the we have the right
language well i think it's the right
language i mean i think it's a pretty
useful language uh we have the rule of
law we have we have great great
universities some of the world's best
universities
are in this country and dispersed across
this country we have a cultural and
media footprint so massive
that peppa pig
is which i know a lot about at the
moment peppa pig is teaching
is teaching kids in america to say
tomato and petrol and mummy instead of
mom apparently
and there are three current contestants
for the world number one uh hit there
and they are they are adele and coldplay
and ed sheeran and if you're really
worried about the weather which i can't
believe you are let me remind you as i
never tire of saying that it actually
reigns more in rome this is the great
cultural mullanex of of the world it is
the cyclotron of talent we already
attract huge sums of inward investment
more than anywhere else in this
hemisphere and this is the moment when
we in the uk want to lengthen that lead
uh this summit has already by its own
standards been a success because we've
raised a further 10 billion of inward
investment uh securing thirty thousand
creating thirty thousand uh new jobs but
you will remember that moment in trading
places
when eddie murphy and dan aykroyd have
been selling selling selling pork
bellies or i think maybe it's frozen
concentrated orange remember this bit
sell sell sell and then they they turn
and they look at each other with a wild
gleam
in their eyes
and they look at the clock
and they buy buy bye
and now is that time my friends now is
the moment
now is the moment for you to consult the
atlas of investment that we've provided
for you now is the time for you to buy
into a country that has long standing
and natural advantages as a home for
investment but which is now changing and
building on those advantages and moving
in an exciting new direction with a
green industrial revolution with new
regulatory freedoms and a new mission to
unite and level up across the whole of
the united kingdom come with us on that
journey and i can tell you the uk
government will be with you every step
of the way thank you very much and i
hope you enjoy the summit thank you